omg my girl rihanna finally on the red
carpet at the met gala we have all been
waiting for this moment and she is
making it official with asap rocky
breeze yeah rihanna asap
[Music]
so cool
why was tonight the night you and reeve
had to make it official all american
kids
that's what american voice
why does it work with you and riri
what is it about that lady it represents
america right like different cultures
a red carpet official
we're all ready together
what are you wearing
it's so good to see you this is
nashville
it's happening yes
you got it
yes and i'm i was so flattered
yes i don't i didn't respect you because
i don't know if i could make it make it
okay but i really want to
and i love nashville oh and we love and
i love you hi amanda hi how are you i'm
so good it's so good have fun and honey
i hear you're having the party of all
parties tonight
i got to work in the morning y'all
making me work when regis invited me to
her after party
oh my gosh
rihanna and i finally reunited at the
met gala but most importantly here
asap rocky and rihanna making their
relationship official on the carpet
over the shoulder over the shoulder
yes mama
oh
hey
and the crowd goes wild what we have
been waiting for brianna and her plus
one asap rocky
oh
all the love
[Music]
oh my gosh what's going on here
turn back
[Music]
[Applause]
did you let reestana under your umbrella
tonight
i've been working on i know i'm here all
night guys you worked on that all week
all week brave
[Music]